some of these stories are so
unbelievable that they actually do seem
like they're not real except they are
and I've talked about the problem with
calling them unbelievable because it
actually creates a sort of disbelief of
things that are all too real and should
horrify us and this is going to be sort
of a short story since it's still
developing I did want to briefly cover
it a top Trump national security adviser
has been reportedly escorted out of the
White House and placed on leave when it
was uncovered that they were potentially
a security risk remember we were told
Donald Trump can be trusted to hire the
right people then he can be trusted with
sensitive information with information
security all of that stuff Hillary
couldn't be trusted except then Trump is
filling secrets to Russian spy
recruiters in the Oval Office using
unsecured devices that he refuses to
have screened and here appears to have
someone who's a security risk working in
the White House I'm talking about a guy
named Andrew peek Andrew peek is or was
the senior director for European and
Russian affairs at the National Security
Council this is like one of trumps top
Russia advisors he is now on leave and a
security investigation is taking place
Trump had someone on the National
Security Council previously at the State
Department his top person on Russia
involved in all sorts of sensitive areas
and that guy had to be escorted out of
the White House by security the White
House was asked for comment they said we
don't discuss security matters which of
course confirms that this is a security
matter a peek himself was asked to
comment said no comment so it's not just
that Donald Trump is hiring bad people
he's hiring people who are potentially
security threats that security has to
escort out but the bigger picture issue
is that this is the third time in a year
that this position is vacant never mind
other positions of importance and
someone sent me a funny message because
peak advises Trump on Russia stuff I got
an email that said hey David do you
think Peake was escorted out because it
were was revealed he's in cahoots with
Putin or do you think he was escorted
out because it was revealed that he's
not in cahoots with Putin and that
doesn't work for Donald Trump very
clever at the
point it's all speculation I actually
think that the entire security threats
story might be false and I'll explain
what I mean by that Andrew peak was an
intelligence officer for a long time he
has a doctorate in International Affairs
he was appointed I believe by David
Petraeus under the Barack Obama
administration it's possible that Trump
missed this guy in the firings of Obama
people and now after the Iranian Fiasco
it's possible Peake started speaking out
saying what you're doing is crazy and
then it was realized by the Trump
administration oh damn how did this guy
slip through the cracks he's got to go
let's escort him out and say that
there's a security investigation going
on I it's mere speculation it's all
crazy I don't know what the final
resolution would be but remember it was
Trump who said I will hire the best
people
it was Trump who said the people around
me are just going to be the best and you
know that if you want proof that
trumpets were bamboozled by that line
think back to someone else who tried to
use that same bullet point and was
excoriated Herman Cain Herman Cain is
this pizza entrepreneur who ran for
president for the Republican nomination
I want to say it was 2012 although maybe
it was in 2008 it can you imagine if
that was 12 years ago it feels so recent
anyway Herman Cain ran for the
Republican nomination and one of the
things that Herman Cain started saying
early on when he was asked about what
would your policy be in Afghanistan or
you know people were asking policy heavy
questions he would say haven't figured
it out yet but I'm gonna put the best
person in charge of figuring that out
and maybe his followers sort of bought
it but the Republican Party at large did
not buy it and he was completely laughed
at and his campaign fell apart
relatively quickly after he said that on
the other hand you've had Donald Trump
effectively saying the same thing which
is that Donald Trump did a better job of
pretending to know about stuff like
trade and health care or whatever but he
also pushed a lot of the same idea that
he was going to hire the best people he
was going to drain the swamp to put the
best people in it's really the same
failed idea that Herman Cain put forward
about I'll figure it out when I get
there and I'll put people in place who
are going to know
but with Donald Trump at work then it
actually succeeded at bamboozling enough
of his followers and even enough
Republicans who said I trust that Donald
Trump is going to take our advice and
Trump sometimes alluded to that by
saying hey you know what I will select
justices to the Supreme Court from a
list given to me by I think it was the
Heritage Foundation I will select judges
for lower court levels from lists that
are generated by this group or that
group so Trump was equally clueless
about a lot of these policy issues but
he played the game about hiring the
right people of course it was a complete
and total farce and he didn't do that
and a whole bunch of his people have
been indicted if not forced out for
different reasons many of them
internationally embarrassing privacy
calm is one of our sponsors and they're
giving you $5.00 just for using their
free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works when you pay for
something online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn from your checking account but
your real card number stays completely
private and you do it all with one click
you can autofill the card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you on
expectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you five dollars to
spend just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman